I'm going to start with I've seen seven
episodes of season 4 For All Mankind I
love the show so much that's all I have
on that we'll talk about that at another
Point uh what's cooler uh working with
Nicholas Cage or John Woo o that's uh
that's quite a face
[Music]
off yeah I don't know that's a hard one
um okay I'll ask a different question um
I know you're a fan John Woo so I am
curious what did it actually cost you
what did you pay to be in the movie yeah
no the whole budget you know so I'm I'm
I'm the sole Finance here of this film
so I mean but for real though I I know
you're a movie fan I know you're an
action fan what did it actually mean to
you to work with someone like John
because for me I mean this is my first
time getting to talk to him today I
couldn't believe I was talking to him
yeah no I know um yeah it it was a bit
of a dream come true I had this
conversation with basila wanic and ER
Lee um and we the producers of John Wick
and we just done uh Informer and uh and
we all really wanted to find something
new and and Basel was like well look I
got uh this film John Woo wants to come
back I was like what and I was like and
and it's a film that doesn't have any
dialogue
like okay I don't need to read that I'm
in what is it like though I want to be
specific about this so obviously there's
there's no dialogue you don't you don't
speak in the film as an actor this is a
pretty part big part of a performance so
for you what is it like on set where
you're emoting just through your eyes
and your facial expressions and you know
what I mean yeah it was uh you know I
had some friends that were joking around
and they were like ah great now we can
get to hang out while we're shooting
because you're not gonna have to go home
and learn your lines and I was like it's
I don't think it's gonna be easier like
I don't think and and and I realized
really quickly that um it was a lot more
demanding um usually like the text
and you know it it sort of anchors you
in the scene but it also helps Propel
the emotions and and you know it's it's
it's really a crutch to to sort of get
emotionally and into the scenes and and
also of course it helps you tell the
story of the scene cuz you're saying
things sure um so I really quickly
realized that I needed like a different
level of emotional preparation before
each take so I also because this is the
whole narrative here is so driven by
this man's inner rage and you know the
sadness and his fire and hatred um so I
I really needed to like engage all that
for every take so it was it was it was
very demanding when you were looking at
the schedule and what you had to
accomplish with the you know what you
had what was the day you had circled in
terms of this is going to be a real pain
in the ass or I cannot wait to film this
uh I mean I think I felt both of those
things for most of the
days um I knew when we were going to
shoot the the stair sequence um that
that was going to be really rough
because it's also in Mexico City so it's
at elevation uh so running upstairs uh
is about twice as uh tough there the
first time we did it I was like like I
thought I was in good shape but like I'm
destroyed um so that was that was a
really heavy tough just physical
sequence
um um and and also I got you know we
were shooting in some weird location you
know some old parking lot building that
was semi- torn down or never finished to
get built and when we were scouting it
like all of a sudden you were like oh
that's like a 90ft drop so like so maybe
we should put a little sign here you
know and there was like oh there's a big
metal like thing just sticking out that
you know could be someone's eye that
disappears so there was a lot of work in
just making it into an environment where
we wouldn't like die um you know going
through with the film and you know a lot
of the stantis were doing some pretty
you know tough stair Falls in like
narrow staircases and you know falling
15 20 feet you know you just a little
bit too much to the left and you Bang
Your Head uh after a 20ft fall and it's
you know not a good day uh this is the
reason why uh they don't let me do
stunts because I would die on in one
second on that note sir it is always a
pleasure to talk with you I wish you
nothing but the best love having the the
dog at the junk uh cool great to see you
again
man